Thanks, everyone.
So...
My name is Parsha.
I'm going to talk to you guys
about mixing JavaScript and CSS.
So...
Before I start, I want to warn you.
This talk is about ideas, not code.
Even though I'm going to be showing you
a lot of code, I'm not necessarily saying
it's a good idea or that it'll
even work.
My goal here is to share some ideas and get
you guys thinking.
So
if you hear anything that you think is awesome
and might solve your problems,
or if you think I'm totally crazy, then you
should come find me and tell me
about it.
So...
Before we talk about JavaScript, let's talk
about CSS.
CSS enables us
to take websites that look like this, and
turn them into this.
CSS even
makes Craigslist look better.
Going from this to this.
I didn't even think
Craigslist used CSS.
Aside from enabling rich user interfaces,
CSS also lets
us create cool animations and visual effects.
Like whatever this is.
It's not
showing up on the projector.
So I'll show you on my screen.
It's kind of
neat.
This is an animation utilizing the GPU, to
compose several layers
together and transform them on top of each
other.
Oh, there it is!
So yeah.
CSS is pretty awesome.
But...
CSS has its fair share of issues and
limitations too.
There's no way to define constants.
There's no way to extend the language with
your own logic.
There's basically no dependency management.
We have to
implement the rule, but there's limiting performance
characteristics
there.
There's no way to reuse code or do any sort
of metaprogramming.
And
there's no interoperability with the rest
of our front-end code, JavaScript.
Sometimes these limitations are good.
They force us to write easy to
understand code, but sometimes, especially
in large scale apps, these
limitations often lead to copy and pasted
code and stuff that's hard to
maintain.
But we've been able to work around these issues
by creating new
languages we call CSS pre-processors.
Letting us work around some of these
issues, at least.
But pre-processors are weird.
They often have ambiguous syntax and
non-standard semantics, and they give us features
that look and smell like
things we're used to, like functions, but
then their behavior is different
in unexpected ways.
Let me show you a couple of examples of what
I mean.
Let's take a look at Silas.
It has very terse syntax.
Basically gets rid
of things like semicolons, curly braces, colons
-- basically almost
everything.
Let's take a look at this example.
Here's the compiled output.
We get what we would kind of expect.
There's a form that gets the color
applied to it, and then an awesome font applied
to input and text areas inside
that form.
But what would happen if we accidentally swapped
two
lines in our stylus source?
So in case you didn't see that -- let me do
it
again.
The top two lines get swapped with each other.
Well, this no longer
really makes sense.
The source doesn't make sense.
What do you guys think will happen?
Hopefully we get some sort of compile
time error.
Nope.
Stylus gets a bit confused and instead thinks
our color
declaration is actually a selector.
This is still valid CSS, so there's no
error.
Hopefully the developer catches this.
But it's going to take some
effort to debug.
Let's take a look at Less.
Less gives us a way to import
dependencies.
Actually, Less gives us eight ways to import
And
they all have their different semantics.
Actually, sometimes they have the
same semantics as others, depending on the
condition of what we're
importing.
Basically you end up having to look at the
docs, every time you
want to import something.
Let's look at variables.
Sass gives us variables.
Here we have a variable
defined called heading color, and then we
use that to set the color of H2
elements.
But we're defining the variable twice.
Once before we use it and
once after we use it.
In the output, Sass uses the first assignment
of the
variable and we get red.
But let's see what Less decides to do.
You have the
same thing, but here Less does the opposite
thing.
Less uses the value that we
last assigned to the variable, and we get
the value white.
Weird.
Maybe
not either of them are wrong...
But you've just got to get used to it, and
make sure you switch into the right context
when you go between languages.
Less also lets us do arithmetic.
Here we see 10 pixels, minus 2 pixels is 8
pixels.
Great.
But you'd better be careful with spaces, because
adding or
removing spaces might change the result.
That's right.
Whitespace-sensitive
math.
And you'd better be careful with parentheses
too, because parentheses
will change the results in an even worse way.
So what else can Less do?
Less
has this awesome feature -- it can automatically
convert units for us.
So
here we have the same values, but using different
units.
10 centimeters minus
1 centimeter, and 10 centimeters minus 10
millimeters.
Both come out
to 1 centimeter.
Cool!
Let's see this in action with division.
Here we have
the same units on both sides of the operator.
10 centimeters divided by 1
centimeter. 10 centimeters, as you would expect,
but what happens if we mix
units like we did with subtraction.
Doesn't work!
Less silently ignores units on the second
operand when you're doing division.
So...
With Less, we can do arithmetic, but you've
got to be really careful.
So my point is: language design is hard.
Syntax, scoping, types, compilers,
error handling -- all these are really complicated
things.
It's understandable
that these pre-processors have gotten some
of them wrong.
So...
CSS is cool.
But it's got issues.
We've got pre-processors to solve some of
these issues,
but pre-processors have their own issues.
Is there a better way?
Can we use
JavaScript to do CSS better?
Well, let's take a look at what using
JavaScript to write CSS might look like.
Let's express a simple rule in
JavaScript.
Here it is in CSS.
You've got a red button.
Let's convert it to JavaScript.
It's actually not too different.
You basically add some quotation marks,
change out the semicolon to a comma, and you've
got valid JavaScript
syntax.
All right.
That's a pretty basic example.
What if we had
pseudoselectors?
You wanted to have a hover state for our button.
Well, it's
not too much different from CSS or one of
our pre-processors.
And we can do
even more complicated selectors.
Child selectors and descendant selectors.
Still nothing too surprising, I hope.
And here's the media query.
And in
CSS, sometimes you want to do something called
property fallbacks, where
we define a property more than once, so that
browsers that don't support
a certain value can fall back to previous
ones.
In JavaScript, we can't define the same property
more than once in an
object, but we can use arrays to accomplish
this.
CSS also has a bunch of
other @rules.
@charset, @fontface.
Rest assured we can express all these
things using JavaScript.
So you've got rules with selectors, you've
got
pseudoselectors, child selectors, any kind
of selector, really.
Property
fallbacks, media queries, @ rules.
That's pretty much all of CSS.
So I think
it's safe to say we can express CSS using
JavaScript.
And it's pretty
simple too.
All we're using are literals.
Literal expressions.
This is
essentially JSON.
So we can express CSS in JavaScript, but how
do we actually use this
JavaScript -- this JavaScript in a browser
to style elements?
So far,
we've got these plain old JavaScript objects,
but we need to turn this in a
way that -- into something that the browser
understands.
Well, all we
really need is a function that can transform
one of these objects into a CSS
source string.
Now we can take the CSS source string and
let the browser
use it.
So, yes, we can express CSS using JavaScript,
and we can use
that to actually style elements in the browser.
Awesome!
JavaScript for
everything!
But why would we want to do this?
Are there any actual
advantages?
To start with, remember the issues and limitations
of CSS that I raised in the
beginning of this talk?
The reasons we've invented all these new languages,
the CSS pre-processors?
Well, JavaScript solves -- or at least addresses
--
all of these issues for us automatically.
Let me show you what I mean.
CSS
has no way to define variables.
Less and Sass both give us this ability, but
they both have their own weird semantics.
JavaScript has variables
built in, and with semantics we know and understand.
We can use
variables to define our constants in one place.
JavaScript also has
arithmetic built in.
10 minus 2 pixels is 8 pixels.
And best of all,
unlike some CSS pre-processors, it doesn't
matter how many spaces or
parentheses you use.
You still get 8 pixels.
In CSS, we have no way to
extend the language with our own logic.
Say we wanted to mix two colors
together.
In CSS, you would have to pre-compute this
value, and hard code it into our
source code.
Less and other pre-processors give us a set
of built-in functions
that we can use to do some basic things.
But we still can't define our own
logic.
With JavaScript, we can define arbitrary functions.
Here we create a
function that mixes the two colors for us.
We can even share this function
with the rest of our front-end code.
Of course, we don't actually have to
write our own functions.
We can take advantage of the JavaScript ecosystem
and use modules to do the work for us.
Here we're using the color module from
NPM to do the mixing of the two colors.
And we're not limited to just
functions that operate on colors or single
values.
In JavaScript, functions
are the most basic unit of code reuse.
We can use functions to generate entire sets
of style declarations.
Here we
have a function that takes in a base color
and generates styles for a
button based on that color.
We're getting the same sort of code reuse
we get
as what some pre-processors call mix-ins.
But with semantics that we
understand.
With CSS, we have no way of sharing values
between CSS and the
rest of our front-end code.
For example, here we have some CSS that defines
a color.
Then say we have some JavaScript code that
draws on a canvas, and
we want this canvas drawing to have the same
color as we defined in CSS.
I'm
sure you guys have probably run into something
like this before.
You end
up having to leave comments to tell other
developers that when they
change one of these variables or one of these
values, they have to make
sure they go into the other place and change
that value to match too.
This is brittle.
But if our styles are in JavaScript, and our
canvas
code is in JavaScript, it becomes trivial
to share values between the two.
Of
course...
We don't need everything to be a single file.
We can use modules to
organize our styles and import dependencies.
And it's just JavaScript, so we
can import whatever we want.
Constants, functions, or entire sets of style
declarations.
Speaking of modules, we can take advantage
of NPM.
Not only
do we have access to the 150,000 modules -- we
can use NPM to publish and
reuse style modules.
Imagine having an ecosystem of reusable styles
for
things like buttons and tables and other common
interface elements.
Or
utility modules that help you build styles.
For example, a module that
takes in a background color and automatically
generates a foreground
color for you that has good contrast.
Spoiler -- that module already exists
in NPM.
So I've shown that there are advantages of
using JavaScript to write CSS.
By
using a Turing-complete programming language
to build our styles, we're not
limits to what our CSS pre-processor has implemented.
We can instead
use the full power of JavaScript to implement
whatever logic we need.
We
don't need to reinvent variables, functions,
scoping, or anything else.
JavaScript has all of these things, just waiting
to be used.
Of course, with
great power comes great responsibility.
Maybe it's not a good idea to do a
network request to build your styles.
But that should be up to you to
decide.
So...
We've successfully used JavaScript to write
CSS.
How else can
we mix JavaScript and CSS?
Let me pause for a second and tell you that
you should consider the
following experimental thinking.
The details are vague.
I don't know if it's
a good idea.
And I definitely don't know if it'll even
work.
So think about
it and give me your feedback.
But let's see how else we can mix JS and CSS.
We can use JavaScript to apply styles in the
browser.
What I mean by
this is taking over the browser's role of
parsing CSS and applying styles to
elements.
I know this sounds crazy, but bear with me
for a second and let's
see what we can do if we do this.
First, writing CSS and JavaScript, like
I've been talking about, is not a prerequisite
to this.
You could just use
regular old CSS, actually.
What is a prerequisite is having some sort
of CSS abstract syntax tree or CSS
AST available to us in the browser.
What I mean by this is: we need to be able
to take a CSS source string and be able to
understand and inspect it
and see exactly what's being defined in that
source.
Of course, there's
an NPM module for that.
Here we're parsing a simple CSS rule.
We have
access to the selector, the declarations,
what property is being defined,
and what the value is.
And of course, we can do the inverse.
We can take a
CSS abstract syntax tree, and generate a CSS
source string.
Cool.
But
what does this enable us to do?
Well, CSS has a new feature called CSS
feature queries.
It's kind of like media queries, but instead
of testing the
device's width or orientation or something
like that, we're able to test
whether a device supports a certain CSS feature.
This example lets us use Flexbox, if the browser
supports Flexbox.
Otherwise
we use float.
Unfortunately, not many browsers support feature
queries
yet.
But if we're executing JavaScript in the browser,
then we have
access to information about that browser environment.
Like, for
example, whether or not the browser supports
a certain CSS feature or not.
And if we can access our CSS abstract syntax
tree, like I showed earlier, then
we can use that information about the browser
and transform our CSS into new
CSS.
Then we can take that new CSS and inject it
back into the browser by
injecting a new style tag into the documents.
This means we can take CSS and
create new CSS based on what browser we're
in.
We can use this technique to
polyfill CSS feature queries.
We would walk the CSS abstract syntax tree,
and then when we come across an @supports
rule, we would do the feature
detection in JavaScript.
And then based on the result of that feature
detection, we could generate a new CSS AST.
Either including the rule or
excluding the rule that's nested under the
app supports rule.
Now we have
feature queries in every browser.
So what else can we do?
One of the browser's
jobs in CSS is to take selectors and figure
out which elements match.
Then the matched elements get styles applied
to them.
In this example, the
browser knows to apply the color red to our
span because the span is a child
of a div element.
That's what our CSS rules selector specifies.
The
other way we can take over the browser is
by doing this matching and applying
of styles ourselves.
This means for each CSS rule we have defined,
we would
find all of the elements that match, using
something like query
selector all, and then for each matched element,
we would apply the rule's
styles to the element.
Why would we do this?
The browser already does this
for us.
Well, again, it's about having new information.
This time we
would have information about the hierarchy
of elements in the document
when we're applying styles to an element.
Meaning that for each element we're
applying styles to, we could see what its
parent is, what its children are,
how many siblings it has, we would know exactly
where in the document's
hierarchy that element is.
This information lets us polyfill even more
CSS features.
Take first child
and last child, for example.
If you know about the siblings of an element,
you
know the position of an element within its
parents, then we know if
it's the first child or not, and if it's the
last child or not.
This means we
would be able to implement first child and
last child ourselves.
So when
we're iterating through elements, we can use
this information about the
element's position to determine if the element
should get our first
child's or last child's styles.
Though that's not really too useful, since
basically every browser supports first child
and last child natively.
But
with the same kind of information, and the
same technique, looking at the
document's hierarchy, maybe we can polyfill
something more useful.
Flexbox is a new CSS layout feature that makes
it easy to express all the
crazy things.
We use floats and tables and various other
layout hacks.
If you know the Flexbox styles we want to
apply to an element, and we know
that element's parents and its children and
all the styles of those
elements, then we can calculate the position
and dimensions of every
element.
This example has a flex container with two
children.
Each with an
equal grow factor of 1.
This means we would have a container that
has two side
by side columns inside of it, each with equal
width.
I was able to
determine that by just looking at the CSS
and our document's hierarchy.
Of
course, computers can do this for us too.
And you guessed it -- there's an
NPM module for that.
So if we can describe our document, creating
a
representation of our document hierarchy and
the styles we want each element
to have, then we can use the CSS layout module
to calculate the layout of our
elements.
So here we're describing the document I showed
in the previous example.
A
container with two flex children.
So if we pass the right information to
CSS layout, it can calculate the exact dimensions
and positions of each
element for us.
Here we can see we end up with our parent
and two children,
side by side, each with equal width.
We get the width, height, top, and
left of each element.
That's awesome!
I think we can use that to implement a
runtime Flexbox polyfill.
I think we're in a really exciting place right
now.
The JavaScript module ecosystem is implementing
some great
things.
I think it's going to be really interesting
to see what we
can do with them.
So I hope I've shown you some interesting
ways you can
mix JavaScript and CSS.
And essentially reimplement the browser in
the browser.
Come find me and talk to me about any of this.
I would love to
discuss it.
You can also tweet me @ParshaP.
Thanks for your time!